un equipo de rescatistas palestinos se
ha sumado a la ayuda internacional tras
el terremoto en Turquía y Siria el más
letal en medio oriente en casi un siglo
desde ramala hoy partieron 73 miembros
de la agencia de cooperación
internacional Palestina un equipo
integrado por rescatistas de defensa
civil personal de la medialuna roja
Palestina y del Ministerio de salud
local todo se van a repartir de forma
equitativa para asistir tanto en Turquía
como en Siria en principio para una
misión de 10 días aunque podría
extenderse de ser necesario y ese de que
la catástrofe tiene Ecos Aquí también no
solo por las varias réplicas menores que
se han ido sintiendo en Jerusalén sin
Jordania e Israel sino también porque
entre las víctimas de este terremoto hay
al menos 72 refugiados palestinos Además
así como ocurre con la población Siria
alrededor de 57.000 refugiados
palestinos en Siria Necesitan ayuda
urgente según urhua la agencia de la ONU
que está recibiendo a miles de afectados
en sus instalaciones en el norte de este
país árabe Mientras tanto Turquía ya se
encuentran casi 400 oficiales de las
fuerzas de defensa de Israel con cientos
de ellos apoyando las tareas de búsqueda
y rescate bajo los escombros y de hecho
en las afueras de calaman marash
epicentro del sismo de magnitud 7,8 esta
misión israelí instaló un hospital de
campaña para atender a los heridos se
espera que estos equipos permanezcan en
Turquía de 9 a 14 días aunque también si
la emergencia lo requiere podrían
quedarse por más tiempo